heureux montagnards de paris ils
n'avaient pour sym que le montparnasse
où la butte montmartre ils viennent de
découvrir la tour eiffel se pique de 300
mètres qui domine la vallée de passy et
à la veille de noël trois alpinistes
encore des hauts risques et l'ascension
la plus extraordinaire est la plus
imprévues
première plateforme apaise jusqu'ici ce
n'était qu'une porte maintenant c'est un
mur vertical et l'on verra sous l'oeil
des caméras bel accrochés aux poutrelles
nos trois alpinistes coller comme des
mouches à la surface de cette aiguille
de faire
de mémoire de tour eiffel il n'y a pas
de précédent et paris qui ne s'étonnent
pas facilement on avait quand même
j'avais jusque là pour la première fois
on a violé la tour eiffel